Trump could announce some new service or
some group overnight and destroy Twitter
in 1 minute so let's just say suck is
watching right now say Sandberg's
watching Larry Page Sergey you know
you'd folks at YouTube they are owned by
Google doors all these guys are watching
right now would you ever want to be you
know figuring out a way to be letting
you know be back on these social media
platforms or you're okay if they never
ever let you back on again are you okay
with that never again I'm Alex I'm Alex
Jones I'm never changing whether you
take me back or not I am never changing
a single way I do anything I don't care
if I'm ever back on it is that where
you're at today well obviously they're
like 90% of the internet obviously I
want back on that okay but they
misrepresent everything I've said and
done it's like Jack Dorsey went on a
month ago on NBC CNN ABC all of it he
went on with less they're holding Joe
Nocera like Joan says he wants to kill
the media with assault rifles endorsed
he goes Jack Dorsey those I know it's
horrible but he can stay I never said
that so but Dorsey the first time he
defended you to think that was all like
acting like he was I talked to folks
over in the meeting with him when I
confronted Marco Rubio who walked up to
the press conference
Jack Dorsey said oh my god now he's been
mean to a Republican this is that done
they are now I can ban him who told you
that are you assuming that or who knows
people who know if he wasn't meeting
people in the meeting telling you that
now that you're going after Marco Rubio
this is an opportunity for Dorsey to ban
on and talk to folks that were in the
meeting with check talk Dorsey okay and
he goes oh I can ban Alex Jones down I
just wanted for a Republican that's how
dumb they are I mean it's a total joke
do you think doors is a trump fan no
okay we both know that he's not how come
he hasn't been Trump he's more powerful
than you are there's there's a reason
why how come Trump's not because it's
way obvious he's already one of the
worst banners out there and so by
leaving Trump up there
Trump could announce some new service or
some group overnight and destroy Twitter
in one minute yeah but the point I'm
trying to make to you is I don't think
Dorsey I actually think Dorsey defended
you and by the way I am NOT on Dorsey
said politically I actually that's not
know he only did it for he only did it
for cover but you and I both know if
let's just say he isn't he's helping out
the Hillary Clinton fire but how come
Dorsey hasn't done something to Trump he
could easily do it what if he does move
but he could have done that pre election
time so I I think there is something
that happened two T's I wish I hope Jack
Dorsey takes Trump off Twitter that will
blow up in his face pecked know he knows
he was scared to even take me off and
then when I got in Rubio's face he
literally said oh god that's our cover
get rid of it so you think the tipping
point was Rubio oh I know people are on
the meaning
why would Rubio be a tipping point you
confronted somebody he disagrees with no
no no do you think he's under really
thought it was no he thought it was
bipartisan he thought oh look he's mad
at Republicans that's how dumb they
aren't I get he's a big tech head and
all this stuff now knows Rango do you
remember back in the days when Beck used
to be the main guy to watch on Fox him
in O'Reilly would go at it and he was
coming up and he would get up and he
would do his shows and I was on Beck one
time and he would show this outside yeah
it was like yeah yeah and Hitler did
this and you know and everybody oh my
gosh this could be conspiracy and it's
tight you know and even rush but these
guys haven't been banned off Twitter
these guys haven't been banned off
YouTube you've been banned so what is
that part of it because well let me read
something let me just watch it